Guten Morgen Thomas.
Guten.
Du ich frage mich ob wir für Österreich einen Segensgebet senden soll.
Das ist natürlich klar dass wir nicht nur jetzt bieten sollten sondern auch in Zug.
Aux
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 306 vom 8.10 Juni 2019 und ihr habt ihr schon gemerkt
tendinosis heute mal außer ist.
Der Rettung der Welt und daher uns gedacht weil es ja so viel anders gibt scheint mir mal wieder ein wenig nach Österreich und beleuchten weil die Welt aus der Perspektive denn da ist ja die Welt noch in Ordnung.
Ja jetzt gerade wieder sind wir so es ist ein sehr entspannter Sommer da wird hätte keiner gerechnet.
Arm es gibt auch genügend trivia und verrückte Dinge die passiert sind die es wert sind dass in einer nett politischen oder insgesamt Pulli.
Ah ja und da ist ja auch immer so angemessen ist die Witze von heute zu erklären weil das einfach alles zu viel Komplexität hat zwar auch unbedingt hier irgendwie diesen Clip Einspielen der uns gerade so.
Flachwitze motiviert hat was bitte ist das soll ich das mal einspielen erstmal.
Aux
Haben.
Was bitte ist da wieder jetzt kaputt gegangen.
Also wir haben jetzt Wahlkampf in Österreich und was wir gerade gehört haben war eine christliche Veranstaltung in der Wiener Stadthalle die Stadthalle ist so einer der größten,
Konzerthallen für Veranstaltungen die man in Österreich finden kann mit
tausenden Leuten und der war eincremen ricanische Priester der Sebastian Kurz auf der Bühne gesegnet.
Midlife Übersetzung Sebastian Kurz.
Da ziemlich ausdruckslos und ja also die ÖVP zieht gerade alle Register ich werde dann egal dann sind das einzige was ich momentan Führerkult in Österreich passiert.
Aber das ist jetzt nachdem er schon raus gewählt wurde also er ist der stand da auf der Bühne und war nicht mehr Kanzler oder ist das älter.
Genau er ist Altkanzler das ist der normale Terminus für Konzert diesen was sind an obwohl er 32 ist Werder 14 Altkanzler.
Ja also aber beginnen wir mal mit der Chronologie es ist ja eben Podcast auch schon ein bisschen drüber geredet worden ich will ja noch mal kurz so ganz schnell zusammenfassen was Espace.
Was eigentlich immer genau was ist eigentlich passiert.
Genau also wir erinnern uns alle das Strache Video wurde veröffentlicht von Süddeutsche Zeitung und Spiegel das kam am Freitag um 18 Uhr raus ist seiner Zeit für die meisten Redaktionen nicht mehr gut besetzt sind.
Also Freitag welcher Freitag war denn das jetzt das war 31132 drei Wochen ist schon länger her oder.
Ist gut weil ich weiß nicht genau ist auf jeden Fall noch im weißt schon paar Wochen her und jeden Fall das Video wurde vor der veröffentlicht auch gleich 1 geordnet von den Medien
und eigentlich war dann am Freitag schon die Hölle los aber es gab noch keine politische Reaktion
die kam dann Samstagmorgen dann haben alle gewartet sowas sagt jetzt kurz dazu und der hat sich extrem viel Zeit gelassen hat auch immer wieder Pressestatement angekündigt die dann nicht passiert sind.
Und hat sich Zeit gelassen bis 19:45 Uhr ist genau Haupt.
Die Zeit wurde an ein Statement vorgelesen hat und Neuwahlen ausgerufen hat zum frühest möglichen Zeitpunkt inzwischen wissen wir auch dass das.
29 September sein wird und das heißt aber da war kurz noch Bundeskanzler da hat er eigentlich nur gesagt okay
die zwei sind jetzt zurückgetreten und jetzt gibt's mein Neuwahlen und da wurde dann eben auch die Forderung formuliert das Herbert Kickl.
Innenminister zurücktreten muss.
Kurze Anmerkung 17. Mai was die Veröffentlichung von dem Video.
Und ist aber immer noch das beherrschende Thema auf jeden Fall die kurz war noch im Amt
und eigentlich war in Hua 1 Christian Strache als Vizekanzler und Sportminister zurückgetreten kurz wollte dann aber auch noch Herbert
weil mit der guten Begründung schicke war zu dem Zeitpunkt dass dieses Video gedreht wurde.
Bin noch bei Deichmann und also Geschäftsführer Tabata und sozusagen verantwortlich für alle
den seine Korruptionsfälle und als solcher kann er nicht Chef der Polizei sein Chef des Innenministeriums sein das ja in der Aufarbeitung von diesem Fall ganz zentral wäre und.
Gleichzeitig Herbert Kickl ist auch an das ist gibt's so als das Brain innerhalb.
Böses der Stratege war schon unter Jörg Haider und natürlich wäre eine FPÖ ohne diese Personalie weitaus leichter händelbar für die ÖVP
an
unter darf ist die FPÖ aber nicht eingegangen eben weil sie auch sieht dass das eine Bedingung ist die sie in einer sehr langfristig sehr schlechter Position versetzen würde an kiki hat auch eine enorme Basis innerhalb der.
Hörst der Innenminister der meisten zündelt und gegen Ausländer hetzt und das soll ich ja wieder von dieser Partei geliebt Handelskai.
Denke die geht gehen alle Minister aus der Regierung rasend sozusagen das heißt dann kollektionsbuch
obwohl das die Ansage war hat sich kurz davon nicht abbringen lassen und Herbert Kickl entlassen also konkrete gesagt.
Bundespräsidenten Alexander van der Bellen vorgeschlagen Artikel zu entlassen das muss auf Vorschlag passieren und Alexander van der Bellen
unser derzeitiger Bundespräsident der von den Grünen ist es drauf eingegangen hat gegähnt lassen woraufhin die gesamte FPÖ Regierungsmannschaft zurückgetreten ist mit Ausnahme von Karin Kneissl der parteifreien Außenministerin.
Welches welche Figur macht denn
der Bundespräsident in dieser Situation meine der inneren uns das ist ja jetzt auch erst ein paar Jahre her dass er gewählt wurde im Rahmen dieser noch mal wiederholt.
Bundespräsidentenwahl woher ja auch schon gegen einen FDP FDP Kandidaten bestehen musste
und jetzt ist er natürlich in der interessanten Rolle.
Ja und wie du sagst SOA Alexander van der Bellen hat sich durchgesetzt gegen Norbert Hofer von der FPÖ und hätten wir einen FPÖ Bundespräsidenten in der Situation jetzt in den letzten Monat gehabt die ja die Sache vermutlich ganz anders aus also er ist auf
jeden Fall hat er sehr verantwortungsvoll die Rolle ausgeführt die die Verfassung in in solchen Krisensituationen Zuge.
Er hat es geschafft da ausgleichend zu wirken an vielen Stellen und für Stabilität zu sorgen und weil er halt von keiner
was heißt die in den Konflikt involviert ist hat er das finde ich auch sehr gut gemacht er hat dann ein paar Statements gesagt die irgendwie im vielleicht eher negativ ausgelegt wurden eben erwünschte Stabilität.
Arm aber dazu kommen wir noch also auf jeden Fall es war die Situation dass jeden Fall mal die gesamte FPÖ Mannschaft aus der Regierung zurücktritt.
Und A dass die dass die Regierung damit auch keine Mehrheit mehr hat im Nationalrat es im Parlament weil die FPÖ jetzt eben auch nicht mehr an die Kondition gebunden ist und
daraufhin hat sich kurz dazu entschieden eine Minderheitsregierung zu machen er hat die FPÖ Minister ersetzt mit.
Kai friebus das parteifreien neutralen Figuren
und da hat versucht einfach auch seine Kanzlerschaft zu retten weil das Cover ist das jetzt wo es keine mehr hat.
Jochen mehr im Nationalrat gibt ist die Chance für einen Misstrauensantrag frei unsere Verfassung sieht vor ein Misstrauensantrag ist das Instrument für das Parlament eine Regierung loszuwerden
AMS gibt ganz ganz viele solcher Misstrauens Anträge gegen einen Termin ist oder ganze Regierungen und normalerweise gehen die nie durch.
In dem Fall war es jetzt aber so dass der
tote Wittich durchzugehen und eigentlich war dann so in der Woche schon nachdem dass das Video will ist wahr und diese Regierungsumbildung passiert.
Wollte der Nationalrat zusammentreten und diese Sache diskutieren und auch einen Misstrauensantrag stellen aber wolfgang Sobotka der derzeitige
denn des Nationalrats hat das verhindert und hat sozusagen den ganzen noch eine Woche gegeben es ist wurde dann sozusagen in einer Woche eine Regierung eingesperrt die dann.
Am 27.Mai am Montag vom Plenum des Nationalrats zur Gänze
mit deiner Misstrauensantrag zum Rücktritt gebracht wurde also wir hatten sozusagen türkisblau als Regierung dann ganz kurz zu dieser Minderheit Verwaltungs Regierung.
Die aber eh keine Mehrheit hatte und dann war zum ersten Mal
keine Regierung aufgrund eines erfolgreichen Misstrauensantrag in Österreich.
Das war eine Situation die wir vorher noch nie hatten und das ist auch insofern wichtig bei Sebastian Kurz der erste Bundespräsident ist der Misstrauensantrag kassiert hat
Arm und er hat Zeit in den zwei in den letzten zwei Jahren geschafft zwei Regierungen zu sprengen die vorherige rot-schwarze Regierung hat er ja auch maßgeblich zu Fall gebracht.
Armand das haftet ihm jetzt natürlich auch an gerade als junge
hat er sich immer so als der erfolgreiche Saubermann hinstellt und ja aber verfassungsrechtlich was jetzt gar keine Regierung haben geht auch nicht und deswegen hat.
Bundespräsident Alexander van der Bellen.
Hatte sozusagen jetzt die die Möglichkeit eine andere Person mit der Regierungsbildung zu beauftragen
die Verfassung sieht vor dass jeder über 18-Jährige Person die nicht vorbestraft ist und österreichische Staatsbürgerschaft hat mit der Regierungsbildung beauftragt werden kann
am Montag absichtlich mal lange Rätselraten wie mit diesen Auftrag geben würde und er hat sich für Brigitte Bierlein entschieden
das Warten damaligen Zeitpunkt die Präsidentin des Verfassungsgerichtshofs
Arm unter sie war die erste Frau die jemals passiert eigentlich nur Sofas des Gerichtshofs war und eigentlich in ihrer gesamten Karriere war sie immer die erste Frau die ihr jeweiliges Abend gerade in der hatte sie war da sind Weibchen ich glaube in RAL Foto
Poker Tour der in der Justiz war sie also sie ist auf jeden Fall der renommierte Juristin
und sie hat dann innerhalb kürzester Zeit einen Experten Kabinett zusammengestellt für diese Übergangsregierung die wir jetzt bis zur.
Neuwahl 129 September 2019 haben oder eben eigentlich dann auch bis die Koalitionsverhandlungen abgeschlossen sind und es eben eine neue stabile Regierung.
Vielleicht doch länger dauern kann.
Zu dem Thema Experten also erstmal sind jetzt die Ex des das Experten Kabinett was jetzt drin ist identisch mit dem was in dieser einen zwischen Hänger Woche drin war.
Nach der Misstrauensantrag nicht mehr gegen Sebastian Kurz was sondern gegen die gesamte Regierung und damit auch ein diesen Ministerinnen und Minister und das Misstrauen ausgesprochen wurde
jetzt eben sozusagen ihre.
Einräumen mussten das sind gänzlich neue Leute hauptsächlich Menschen aus der Justiz wir haben auch einen Menschen dabei der bei denselben Wehrsportübungen dabei ravi Heinz-Christian Strache also auch jemand der im neonazistischen Umfeld und
existiert das Infrastrukturministerium anführt also man kann in Österreich keine scheinbar keine Regierung ohne Nazis machen das geht irgendwie nicht insgesamt ist das Kabinett aber du hast.
Ausgeglichen und mahnt man hat auf jeden Fall das Gefühl dass die sich ihrer begrenzten Macht bewusst sind dass sie hauptsächlich zur Verwaltung da sind diese Regierung verfügt ja auch über keine Mehrheit im Nationalrat.
Kann keine Gesetze machen ohne dass das von einer Mehrheit die angibt verletzt sich sehr frei bilden kann auch mitgetragen wird es gibt keine einzelne Partei oder zwei Parteien.
Ja
FPÖ Mitglied aber von der FPÖ quasi für dieses Amt bestimmt und man erinnert sich vielleicht dass es die Dame die auf ihrer Hochzeit den Putin eingeladen hat um dann vor ihm dann auch noch herum zu Knicksen und da unterwürfige Posen einzunehmen.
Die ist dann sozusagen mit Misstrauensantrag auch final ausgemustert worden.
Die ist daneben auch mit 3. Juni ausgetreten
Karin Kneissl ich kannte dich schon viel früher bevor sie überhaupt Außenministerin wurde weil sie wir haben mal irgendwie als wirklichen das polizeiliches staatsschutzgesetz kompensiert haben dass die Moni und eingesammelt von Kabarett.
Und von Schriftstellern von allen möglichen Seiten und sie auch als nahostexperten hat sich auch damals gegen dieses überwachungsgesetz gestemmte so ich war bei dir mal zu Hause auf ihrer Farm und habe sie
der Kamera interviewt also die ist
von von manchen ihren Anliegen wird muss jetzt nicht unbedingt der FPÖ zuordnen ich.
Bei ihr was hat eine Frau pontonniers muss als nahostexperten hat sie gesehen da gibt's irgendwie in opening und es macht für die FPÖ sehr viel Sinn einer Partei Freie Person an dieser Stelle zu nominieren weil die app.
Wird das große Problem dass Israel mit der FPÖ keine Termine macht keiner keinerlei Kontakte pflegt und.
Hat sie schon sehr lange weil sie diese Stick mal weg haben wollen und da eine Partei Freie Person zu nominieren was soll bissel die Logik hinter ihrem.
Ministerin scharf und keine Ahnung was die jetzt.
Also die wird wahrscheinlich wieder versuchen in ihren vorherigen Beruf als Expertin zurückzugehen aber sie ist nicht Teil dieser Expertenregierung und.
Ja also es ist aber natürlich spannend weil es gibt einige wichtige Personalfragen jetzt sogar noch gerade auf EU Ebene
indaver Österreich ja eine starke Stimme für Manfred weder WEBER von der Union in Deutschland als Kommissionspräsident das Nachfolger von Junker und
diese Stimme ist jetzt weg gebrochen oder zumindest um einiges leiser geworden.
Nicht die einzigen übrigens die weggebrochen das.
Hoffe da auch dass es da bessere Leute gibt haben an sich natürlich auf die Frage wer denn für Österreich in die Kommission gehen wird die ist auch noch offen
aber unabhängig dessen es gab jetzt auch letzte Woche schon eine Nationalratssitzung wo einige interessante Anträge eingebracht wurden wir haben auch ein Antrag eingebracht um den Bundestrojaner der in Österreich
nächstes Jahr legal werden sollte noch abzuschaffen und wir haben auch irgendwie
drei Parteien dazu gebracht ihn zu unterstützen die FPÖ ist am Ende leider nicht mitgegangen und ja insgesamt wird es jetzt weiter spannend weil natürlich im Wahlkampf Mone Regierung der Nationalrat vielleicht noch mal wirklich nach poliert
stinke weiterbringt oder eben apropolis der Stinker macht die nur für Wahlkampf gut sind das wird man ja sehen es gibt noch ein paar Sondersitzungen die die Parteien noch im
Auto haben und ich finde es an sich auch spannend und gut wenn eine Regierung nicht einfach über die Partei Dinge entscheidet sondern wenn vielleicht wirklich
das freie Mandat im Nationalrat wieder was zählt und mal wirklich mal mit den Abgeordneten reden muss auf Fürsten eigentlich eine Mehrheit gibt und das gute Ideen wären vielleicht kommt dazu ja auch noch.
Aber trotzdem gibt es natürlich immer noch diese rechtskonservative Mehrheit die geht ja nicht weg also das ist ja.
Ja ja das ist.
Aber denkst du weil weil die ÖVP jetzt nicht mit perkolation Vertrag an die FPÖ gebunden ist dass man da noch ein paar bürgerliche Moves durchbringen kann.
Ja das ganz spannend weil eigentlich war so Didi der Versuch der Abmachung zwischen ÖVP,
und FPÖ dass man jetzt nicht Gesetze die man in dieser Regierung beschlossen hat zurücknimmt und sozusagen die eigene Arbeit rückgängig gemacht und die ÖVP hat dann aber mit
diesem dieser Absicht gebrauchen als sie beim Nichtraucherschutz mitgegangen ist die.
Vergangene türkis-blaue Regierung hat den eigentlich geplanten das eigentlich geplante Verbot von Zigarettenrauch in der Gastronomie wieder aufgehoben und das war ein Anliegen der FPÖ und die ÖVP ist da eben.
Mandantenportal mitgegangen hat dieses diesen raucherschutz beschlossen und trotzdem.
Also ist das Gequatsche Hinweise des jetzt sozusagen endlich vorbei.
Ich würde mich noch nicht unterputzventil drauf verlassen dass er das war schon einige Male so.
Dass das hätte sein sollen und ja das dürfte vielen Leuten in Österreich wichtig sein auf jeden Fall ist es die erfülle leider Bundestrojaner nicht mitgeteilt sondern weiter.
Betreuer einer Koalition die es gar nicht mehr gibt die versuchen sich wahrscheinlich jetzt auch gerade zu finden
Arm in den Umfragen sieht man dass die ÖVP obwohl er Sebastian Kurz wirklich.
Einiges an Desaster hinterlassen hat weiterhin sehr weit vorne liegt und eigentlich auch in den Umfragen weit über 30% und
die die die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass Sebastian Kurz der nächste Bundeskanzler von Österreich wird ist zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt immer noch sehr hoch
Anzahl die SPÖ und die FPÖ liegen ungefähr gleich auf
am so um die 20% dass die Opposition nicht mehr aus diesem Desaster herausschlagen kann ist bezeichnend also die SPÖ liegt ähnlich am Boden wie die SPD in Deutschland das ist ja traurig.
Jetzt auf jeden Fall eine Chance mehr Punkte zu machen tun sie aber einfach nicht die Neos ist liberaler Teil unserer FDP und die Grünen liegen auch ungefähr gleich Aufgaben die 10%
A&W die Grünen ist das signifikant weil die ja nicht im Nationalrat vertreten sind die sind bei der letzten Wahl 2017 rausgeflogen und wurden so ein bisschen ersetzt durch die Liste
Pilz die jetzt Liste jetzt
hast und dies hoffentlich bald nicht mehr geben wir da drauf endlich da gibt's Einzelhaft Geräte die sehr gute Arbeit gemacht haben aber die Partei solche der wird wenig Chancen eingerechnet die stehen Moment bei ein Prozent und wir haben eine
4 % Wörter wenn ich bin ich dir oder 5% also ich glaube nicht dass dies rein schaffen werden und
die große Frage ist halt welche Koalitionen gehen sich dabei aus Sebastian Kurz ist nicht nur innerhalb von zwei Jahren geschafft der Regierungen zu Fall zu bringen sondern auch die
die zwei größten anderen Parteien zu stark gegen ihn aufzubringen dass eine mögliche Koalition zumindest schwierig wird natürlich kann sich die hat ja.
Machthunger und der Wille an die Tröge der Macht zu kommen sich durchsetzen so dass die FPÖ sei einfach noch mal macht vielleicht unter anderer Führung und noch bei der SPÖ gibt.
Einen Flügel der eine Koalition sowohl mit ÖVP und FPÖ nicht ausschließt
A&A Denkmal wir aber natürlich auch eine andere mir hat das Sebastian Kurz mit den Liberalen und oder mit den Grünen in einer Koalition geht was vielleicht nicht die schlechteste Option für das Land wäre aus meiner Sicht.
Ohne die SPÖ.
Muss ich rechnerisch ausgehen da muss auf jeden Fall ein sehr gutes Ergebnis abliefern aber denkbar wäre es die Frage ist natürlich auch obwohl liberale oder grüne auch für eine Regierungsbeteiligung bereit werden.
Aber ich glaube das ist so ein Pack matismus gut wäre und die dies
lange noch nicht soweit dass sie sich wieder mit einem klaren Positionen und Inhalten in eine Regierung mit der ÖVP begeben würde die würde einfach wieder gegen die Wand gefahren werden und da wäre keinerlei soziales Profil vorhanden
am und die FPÖ jetzt noch mal an die Macht zu bringen ich meine das war der ursprüngliche Plan also es gibt da vom verhalte gelegt.
Dokumente das so genannte Projekt Ballhausplatz der jetzigen die oder der vorherigen türkis-blaue Regierung der sozusagen der Masterplan von Sebastian Kurz und da war diese Regierung ganz klar auf einer Dekade.
Ausgelegt und davon haben sie jetzt erst sehr wenig umgesetzt da ist eigentlich inhaltlich wenig passiert und auch wenn kurz das nicht mehr.
Stellt Wasser für ein mache ist in Wirklichkeit ist das ja viel PR und Rhetorik dabei und und wenig Inhalt und.
Vielleicht würde ich ihr gerne so über diese PR reden die wir jetzt im Wahlkampf sehen
also hast gerade dieses Siegelung eingespielt es gibt da noch einige andere sehr skurrile Auswüchse in diesem Wahlkampf also schon an dem Tag als der Misstrauensantrag.
Another ist Sebastian Kurz wirklich sozusagen als erster Kanzler jemals
das Parlament irgendwie sich gegen ihn gestellt hat gab es danach einen angeblich spontanes Event vor der ÖVP zentrale was natürlich nicht frontal sondern geplant war mit Bussen die Unterstützer ange.
Haben und einer großen Bühne.
Da gabs dann auch diese diese Szene dimatik habe ich nicht mal das Video findet wo Sebastian Kurz dich die jubelnden Massen geht und seine Anhänger zu der Melodie von go west steh auf Sebastian gesungen haben
Arm und da ist auf jeden Fall ein Führerkult er sich jetzt gerade um ihn bildet und er wird als der Messias Parks in fort
hat dich er wird als der einzige angesehen der irgendwie noch saubere Politik macht und ja diese.
Dieses Bild was da gezeichnet wird wird aber auch schon konterkariert weil jetzt sich natürlich diese ganze investigative Recherche macht in Österreich fokussiert auf die UVP und auf.
Diesen konnten es wird da werden noch alle Vereine und Firmen im Umfeld der ÖVP dich erreicht.
Aber verbindet Verstrickungen mit anderen Wirtschaftstreibenden und das ganze Thema Partei.
Und Adoption ist ja auch immer noch eines was behandelt werden muss von dieser Regierung also mal hofft das ist zumindest im im Bereich antikorruption und
Parteienfinanzierung noch Gesetz
vergeben wird die endlich den Namen verdienen und die die auch dem den Unterlagen Rechnungshof in Österreich aber nicht geprüft Kompetenz geben im Moment ist es einfach auch wahnsinnig leicht in Österreich.
Die Dinge zu
Ton von denen als Christian Strache im in Ibiza gesprochen hatte so nicht an die Partei zu spenden sondern an irgendeinem Verein Staatsaufträge unter der Hand zu vergeben oder transparente Ausschreibung atypische Prüfung von.
Parteienfinanzierung und von von Leistungen die im Wahlkampf geleistet werden wer zahlt die Plakate wer zahlt die Facebook Werbung
diese ganzen Sachen sind in Österreich nicht sauber geredet und eigentlich wäre so ein Skandal wie der den wir gerade haben der Anlassfall diese Regeln nachzuschärfen SG.
Auch eine Kampagne die wir verlinken werden vom Forum Informationsfreiheit die sich genau für solche nach schärfungen einsetzt und hoffentlich auch noch mehr an Aufmerksamkeit erreicht weil ich glaube
an wenn wir das jetzt nicht schaffen schaffen wir es nie in die sind da.
Das haben wir in Deutschland gerade so die Situation dass das
politische fällt komplett von neuen Thema aufgewischt wird also die Klimadiskussion löschbar scheint.
Der Treiber zu sein sicherlich nicht der einzige Grund aber es ist jetzt gerade bei jüngeren wlan glaube ich
Amazon Brandbeschleuniger dass die Grünen Heizung enormen Aufwand haben üblicherweise finden sich ja so gewisse Auswirkungen des deutschen der deutschen Realität auch in Österreich irgendwann wieder aber davon scheinen die Grünen in Österreich nicht profitieren zu können oder.
Na ja ich bin sie sind von unter 4% jetzt auf 10% aufgestiegen und es gibt doch Fernsehdiskussionen die sich,
die Frage stehen so ja ist Klima jetzt das Wahlkampfthema
ich glaube schon dass das auf jeden Fall viel Potenzial hat im Wahlkampf und die ÖVP versucht die jetzt auch lustigerweise als die Umweltpartei darzustellen.
Was sie wirklich nicht ist aufgrund ihres Abstimmungsverhalten es kann man das sagen und gövb war jetzt gebe ich die letzte
30 Jahre in der Regierung also die können sich an der Stelle auch nicht verstecken und
das Thema ist heiß gerade unter den jungen Wählerinnen und man glaubt es kaum es gibt doch viele junge Menschen die Sebastian Kurz wählen und darf da versucht man natürlich.
In der PR auf das einzusteigen aber ob das wirklich auch durchgesetzt daran habe ich starke Zweifel weil die Industrie Interessen einfach überwiegen und die einzigen.
Gerd hat vertreten keine meiner Meinung nach sind die Grünen und ich hoffe dass sie
das zum Beispiel als Hebel nehmen um in eine Regierung zu gehen einfach zu sagen Klimaschutzes jetzt so dringend wir haben nur noch neun Jahre Zeit
bis unser CO2 Budget aufgebraucht ist wir müssen jetzt irgendwie an die Schalthebel um das Schlimmste noch zu verhindern und deswegen können wir jetzt nicht ob das Ozon machen sondern wir müssen mit diesem einen Thema für diese zwei Ministerium
z.b. wirklich auch eine Machtanspruch stellen ich finde das wäre sehr Stimme für das was es gerade.
Alimenten diese Wahlumfragen hier anschaue die haben wir auch verlinkt zumindest hier die die offen neuwal.com verlinkt sind das ist ja schon.
Bemerkenswert also man hat ja so den Eindruck dass die FPÖ jetzt unter diesem Skandal nahezu überhaupt nicht groß.
Leidet.
Das ist
definitiv beängstigend wenn man sieht wie wie groß die Kern WählerInnen schafft der FPÖ ist es ist ja noch dazu so das ist obwohl dieses Video eine Woche vor der EU-Wahl herauskam
und Heinz-Christian Strache daraufhin zurückgetreten ist ja trotzdem so viele Vorzugsstimmen bekommen hat es ihm jetzt ein Direktmandat im Europaparlament zustünde.
Fassungshülsen Stimmen sind sozial man kann in Österreich bei der Europawahl Personen wählen oder.
Genau also wir haben listenwahlrecht du weißt das nicht immer einer Partei und Anna hat halt dann je nachdem wo du bist verschiedene Listen und die Listen haben eine Reihung und über die Vorzugsstimme die du einer einzelnen Person auf dieser Liste gibt kannst du die Reihung beeinflussen.
Du kannst du Leute die ganz unten kandidieren Adi dann sozusagen seit ein Mandat verhelfen das Quorum ist hier in Österreich sehr groß ich glaube der Sprache von zwischen 40 50000 stimmen die ihr wirklich Eisbein bekommen hat
haben und dabei hätte er die Möglichkeit einzuziehen in dieser sehr lukrativ also Europaparlamentarier verdient man sehr sehr gut und
die er hat aber jetzt vor kurzem angekündigt dass er dieses Mandat nicht annehmen.
Ich glaube im Austausch beim Gespräch zu sein seine Ehefrau ein Nationalratsmandat bekommen so dass einer die Familie ist versorgt sollte sich irgendjemand Sorgen gemacht haben.
Und ich würde auch nicht ausschließen dass es Christian Strache noch mal in die Politik zurück geht also der wird jetzt wer der Typ ist geht er jetzt nicht ins Europaparlament sondern bleibt im Abklingen.
Arm und erst wenn klar ist dass er das glatte das vergessen haben z.b. bei der nächsten.
Wien Wahl die wahrscheinlich jetzt in 2020 ist könnt der Spitzenkandidat andreht
das hat aber einfach irgendwie einweihen auch gemacht und man kann sozusagen austesten und.
Kinderärztin Österreich sich verhärtet und das ist auch was die ÖVP auf ihre Plakate schreibt er sozusagen
das jetzt das Volk entscheiden wird sozusagen ja da ist gerade ganz viel grausliche Korruption passiert aber wenn das Volk das irgendwie jetzt das Volk an das jetzt reden über die Wahl könnt ihr sozusagen und seinen Auftrag erteilen und.
Damit sozusagen auch die die eigentliche Moral die eben Politiker der sich im Spiegel schauen sollte er dazu bringen sollte zurückzutreten wird ausgehebelt.
Auf den Plakaten der über die steht auch rot-blau hat bestimmt das Volk.
Entscheiden unser Weg hat erst begonnen das ist eine Anspielung auf den Misstrauensantrag der Sebastian Kurz eben aus dem also aus dem Bundeskanzleramt entfernt hat.
Der nimmt mir jetzt rot-blau hat bestimmt ja seine demokratisch legitimierte Mehrheit im Parlament.
Alle anderen Parteien übrigens auch hat Sebastian Kurz ein Arschtritt gegeben.
Und er sagt dass das war eine Bestimmung R&R voll das Volk wird jetzt entscheiden und dann ganz groß.
Kannst du noch mal ganz kurz die Farbenlehre der österreichischen Parteien Landschaft zusammenfassen weil ich glaube das ist etwas.
Rotis SPÖ blau ist die FPÖ also was bei euch die AFD ist und die beiden und man spricht doch in der ÖVB von einer roten blauen Koalition nur tut jetzt so als wenn eine fliegend gebildete Mehrheit gegen
an den 32-Jährigen Königs Kaiser eine Koalition wäre zwischen diesen beiden Parteien was auch.
Und türkis ist also ÖVP.
War früher schwarz ist jetzt türkis ist im rebinding passiert nie aus die Liberalen sind pink sehr schön zu allem merken das ist die Hello Kitty Farbe und die Grünen sind die Grünen.
Und.
Gelbes keiner sozusagen gibst noch frei.
Nee orange hatten wir auch mal das war das BZÖ das ist die Abspaltung der FPÖ gewesen und da Heirat damals die überlegen sich auch ob sie wieder antreten es ist auf jeden Fall zu hoffen dass es zur Spaltung Erscheinungen innerhalb des rechten Lagers
wir wer jetzt auf jeden Fall wieder eine sehr opportune Zeit ja
an Wer wird dich jetzt sozusagen an vorderster Front dabei sein will als Trendsetter ist die ÖVP hat heute auch Ihr Handy Wallpaper für Sebastian Kurz veröffentlicht wir verlinken
natürlich auch.
Aber muss ja auch sein dieses Massen Gebet für Sebastian Kurz hat er auch Konsequenz.
Ja er hat sich dann distanziert davon und hat gemeint er wusste nicht was da passiert und er waren nur so irgendwie kein zufällig auf diesem Event auf der Bühne und hat sich segnen lassen war im scheinbar dann auch irgendwie peinlich ja also.
Na ja ich meine immerhin ist ja jetzt Jesus Christus aus der Kirche ausgetreten deswegen.
Genau wir verlinken da auch jetzt die Tagespresse das ist unser Postillion in Österreich und ich liebe immer so News Geschichten wo die Satire Zeitungen die beste Quelle sind um zu verstehen was da gerade passiert.
Ja das ist wirklich erstaunlich also.
Aber diese.
Sauser amerikanischer Trend der der mittlerweile auch wirklich Fuß fasst also auch mittlerweile in Deutschland für dich mich mittlerweile durchgeschaut extra3 deutlich besser informiert als über andere Kanäle weil die einfach
die Sachen auf dem.
An
gleichzeitig wenn man sich das aber alles anschaut da wo jetzt wir verlinken auf die Presse auf die Tagespresse und auf die UVP wirft die die Segnung an
diese diese ganzen heimlichen Dinge die jetzt passieren mit Sebastian Kurz zeigen auch dass die PR Maschinerie umbenennen.
Kommen ist davor war das alles eine hundertprozentige message control und die ÖVP war in der Lage alles was passiert ist in ihren narrativ einzupacken und eigentlich.
Keinerlei Kritik an ihrem Kind Kaiser Sebastian Kurz zuzulassen und jetzt bricht das auf einmal jetzt gibt's auf einmal wieder Journalisten die sich.
Auf Twitter kritisch äußern zudem was passiert die auch wieder nachfragen die nach bohren es ist Zeit ist es wieder raus
aufatmen im ganzen Land zu spüren.
Also natürlich.
Genau seid
diese Regierung Zufall gekommen ist ja die die Menschen haben sich in Österreich so ein bissl innerlich schon darauf eingestellt okay dass wir das die nächsten zehn Jahre so weitergehen und es gibt nichts was wir tun können und jetzt ist schon wieder so okay warte mal Recherche.
Kann wirken
dicke dick und das ist das was ich mir dazu denke kann auch mehrheitsfähig sein es gibt Konsequenzen wenn die sich falsch verhalten und das ist
finde ich ein ganz wichtiges mindset in der Demokratie dass wir jetzt gerade wieder haben und das dürfen wir nicht verlieren das muss jetzt wirklich auch bis zur Wahl anhalten und ich hoffe dass sich auch eigentlich sowas wie eine Rücktritt Skulptur in Österreich at.
Die Rücktritte von von Politiker der Politiker in Österreich sind äußerst selten.
Das war ein wichtiger Meilenstein und wir müssen schauen dass das auch zu einem Kulturwandel führt und so leid
artist jetzt rundum das Ibiza Filme der letzten Woche und über den ganzen Sommer passieren werden die am finde ich sehr.
Was ist denn deine These werden dieses Video überhaupt gemacht hat.
Was was was Bruder was kann man denn da auf jeden Fall ausschließen.
Ich glaube da gibt es jetzt eh schon sehr gute Berichterstattung dazu und es wurden noch anzeigen eingebracht ich glaube das dürfte ihn im Umfeld von einem Wiener Anwalt passiert sein und.
Wirklich Leute gewesen sein die da auf eine couragierte Art gesehen haben die app.
Dinge die wir nicht für richtig halten und wir wollen was dagegen tun und wie das Lied ist auch schon in vorherigen folgen gesagt hat du.
Machst du nicht zum Setup mit einer Villa und Fake Oligarchen und all diesen Aufwand.
Ohne dass du die starke Vermutung hast dass die beißen werden und dass die sich auf, Geschäfte auf Kamera einlassen werden
das wird schon viel viel gemunkelt seit vielen Jahren was für Armeen es zwischen rechtspopulistischen Parteien in Europa und.
Russischen Einflusssphären gibt und russischen Geld gibt und diese diese Vermutungen
die hat man in vielen Ländern auch und um Salvini um Le Pen und Wilders und.
Da wäre es nicht weit hergeholt dann eben diese.
Am wahrscheinlichsten Theorie auch mal zu testen mit einem sehr teuren Experiment
und ich glaube auch dass die Menschen die das hier gemacht haben auch wenn die Aufnahmen höchstwahrscheinlich illegal passiert sind weil wir haben keinen one party consent in Österreich
Wer war das wirklich vor Gericht bringen würde würde wahrscheinlich zumindest die die oberen Instanzen vor Gericht sagen ja aber es gibt ja ein überwiegendes öffentliches Interesse und deswegen
er ist gerechtfertigt sozusagen die Straftat der illegalen Videoaufzeichnung zurück.
Aber wenn das jetzt erst jetzt bewerten der österreichischen reicht ja natürlich das Video was in Ibiza aufgenommen wurde es nach spanischem Recht Zuckerwert
und
ich glaube insgesamt geht's hier um Zivilcourage großen Teilen und es freut mich auch wiederum dass viele Journalisten schon wissen auch vom Boulevard Blättern wieder Krone
Ansagen hier ist es ganz klar die Pressefreiheit über der überwiegende Anteil und deswegen ist es gut dass das veröffentlicht.
Armon ich glaube damit haben sie recht ich finde martje gezeigt dass es wirklich ernüchternd gibt und die Leute müssen.
Wissen dürfen wie mit der Republik geschachert wert
und deswegen war das ganze so effektiv und ich glaube dass das auch die Absicht war aber von den Leuten die.
Was die Krone erwähnt dies steht ja so ein bisschen auch im Mittelpunkt des ganzen weil sie von Strachan diesen Video erwähnt wurde Kronen Zeitung ist halt so
Sambal Sauce österreichische Äquivalent
der Bild-Zeitung kann man glaube ich sagen und ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt für linkspopulistische Tendenzen bekannt jetzt.
Ich weiß dein wieder so rüberkam aber so ein bisschen nur diese Unterstellung man können jetzt von außen irgendwelche Russen rein holen die kaufen die dann und dann haben wir das unter Kontrolle das hat den ja auch überhaupt nicht krank.
Aber die die Kronen Zeitung.
Das kommt recht das ist unsere Osterreichische Bild nur dass der Marktanteil dir die Krone Zeitung hat doch um einiges größer ist als der da Bild und diese Zeitung ist bekannte Kompanien Journalismus war auch immer sehr rechts unterwegs.
Abend.
Ist aber in der Tat auch in den letzten Jahren der FPÖ zum Durchbruch verholfen vor allem eben die Online Variante der Zeitung hat er auch so einen Ping Pong spielen mit der.
Sehr großen Facebook-Seite von Heinz Christian Strache die 700.000 Fans hat und Martin sozusagen gerade die Artikel geschrieben die wahrscheinlicherweise von Stachel geteilt werden.
So dass die Facebook Nutzer von ihm auf die Kronenzeitung kommen dort wiederum für Werbeeinnahmen für führen und.
Das war so ein Ping Pong Spiel wo sich jetzt auch der Chefredakteur davon distanziert hat und
nachdem die Kronenzeitung hier wirklich so als Spielball dargestellt wurde und das muss man verstehen dass die Kronenzeitung immer schon irgendwie die unabhängige Conan Zeit.
Meisterteam 7G
nach Abend im Fall des Naziregimes neu gegründet wurde und im Zuge dieser Affäre hat die Kronenzeitung ihr Layout geändert und das unabhängig jetzt noch großer geschrieben weil die Nuggets natürlich schon noch um ihre Glaubwürdigkeit.
Das perfide ist so ein bisschen das
diese Verschwörungstheoretiker hier in dem Stachel Video verbreitet wurde von wegen da wenn es irgendwelche Anteile gekauft und dann bestimmt mir über die Krone Zeitung die wurde ja
im Nachhinein war gemacht dadurch dass der Investor Rene Benko Anteile der Kronenzeitung gekauft hat Orden der war auch schon irgendwie die Gefahr von politischer Einflussnahme die aber EMU ÖVP Umfeld war.
Diese Gefahr ist immer noch nicht gebannt weil die Eigentumsverhältnisse haben sich verschoben die Sensibilität innerhalb der Redaktion ist aber hoffentlich soweit gestiegen
Tendenzen die Zeitungen für Kampagne zu instrumentalisieren schwieriger haben werden wir dich auch durchzukommen oder zumindest von anderen medienkritische begleitet werden aber die Medienlandschaft ist ist berechtigt der Weise einer der der
talking points über die Mara auch reden wird müssen in Österreich ist es so dass.
Parteien und und auch Regierungen massiv investiert und inserieren in
Zeitungen und dass das auch direkten Einfluss hat die gönnerisch über die jeweilige Partei oder das Ministerium berichtet wird
AIDA das obwohl wir in Österreich in der sehr sehr hohe Presseförderung.
Gut dann.
Sind wir ja nach wie vor noch logbuch-netzpolitik was hat denn das ganze jetzt für Implikation
auf den letzten politischen Bereich welche Gelegenheiten ergeben sich hier warst ja schon angedeutet dass ihr da dicke versucht.
Was lässt sich überhaupt für die Bilanz ziehen.
Ja es ist schon viel passiert.
Ich erinnere daran dass diese Regierung in ihrem Regierungsprogramm schon irgendwie ganz viele Netzpolitik drinnen hatte hauptsächlich schlecht aber auch ein paar gute Sachen.
Ein Tier haben vor kurzem zwei so ein Artikel
veröffentlicht Robert die Gesamtschau gemacht haben auf epicenter works eben was alles unter dieser schwarz-blauen Regierung Netzpolitik passiert ist am meisten gesprochen im Park das haben wir den digitalen Ausweis Zwang also das Gesetz für Sorgfalt und Verantwortung in
Abend das hat ungewisse Zukunft an also ich glaube in Österreich wird schwierig dafür eine Mehrheit zu bekommen formal ist es immer noch möglich dass.
Jetzt zu beschließen aber im Moment gibt es keine Regierung die eine Regierungsvorlage machen.
Bitte die dann im Parlament beschlossen wird theoretisch kannst noch dafür eine Mehrheit geben aber nachdem sein ÖVP Projekt war hoffe ich dass die FPÖ jetzt nicht mehr mitgehen wird.
Haben dass das Gesetz wirklich gegen Hass im Netz hilft was er allerdings wurde ihr von vielen Seiten schon kritisiert.
Und ich hoffe dass das zumindest auf österreichischer er wenn er beerdigt werden wird ich verweise aber hier noch auf die Stellungnahme die wir trotzdem noch fertig gemacht haben wo wir ganz viele juristische Argument
gegen so eine kleiner minspeak zusammengetragen haben und nach Dinos in Deutschland diskutiert wird und wenn Manfred Weber Kommissionspräsident würde.
Vielleicht doch auf EU-Ebene kommt sollte man das trotzdem noch im Blick behalten.
An was sonst noch vielleicht nicht kommen wird es eingesetzt digitalsteuer das wehren sich nicht schlechtes.
Da ist leider eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung mit inkludiert indirekt
ital Steuer nämlich nicht die von IP-Adressen sondern auch von location Daten auch eines der Gesetze die im Mai noch fertig konsultiert wurden und
jetzt aber aufgrund der Regierungskrise wahrscheinlich int überfallen es gibt aber leider ein paar Gesetze die es geschafft haben beschlossen zu werden die sind vor allem eben.
Ethischem im Sozialbereich also.
Dann Sozialhilfe grundsatzgesetz und Sozialhilfe Statistikgesetz da werden vor allem Daten von Sozialhilfeempfänger rennen gesammelt und zwar in der zentralisierten Art und Weise und
abends würde auch mal schön als arierparagraph
bezeichnet weil wenn man z.b. Arbeitslose beantragt in Österreich muss man dann die Staatsbürgerschaft der Eltern angeben wofür ist vom Hall überhaupt keinen Grund.
Es gibt da,
natürlich dann auch im Bereich Asyl und Migration Gesetze die vor allem das Auslesen von Handys und Computern von Schutzsuchenden legalisieren in Österreich
Bundestrojaner ist ebenfalls etwas das mit nächsten Jahr legal werden sollte das Gesetz ist leider schon beschlossen
da hoffen wir aber eben vielleicht entweder aufs Parlament dass das noch zurückgenommen wird wenn die FPÖ sich
mal aufwacht und es gibt doch eine Verhandlung beim Verfassungsgerichtshof gegen den Bundestrojaner die ist nächste Woche in 25 Juni
und der Verfassungsgerichtshof hat Zucker wirklich eine öffentliche Verhandlung anberaumt um sich die technischen Argument
geben zu lassen zu dem Thema also da habe ich auch Hoffnung weil so einer mündliche Verhandlung verheißt eigentlich dass das Thema ernst genommen wird
und nachdem dessen Österreich auch massiv diskutiert wurde auch weil wir die ganze Zeit, netter zu machen habe ich große Hoffnungen dass die Richterinnen und Richter sich da vielleicht noch umstimmen lassen an
das ist ja auch wirklich die
die überhaupt mal die Legalisierung von einem Staatstrojaner in Österreich das heißt wenn wir schaffen dieses Gesetz wegzubekommen dann geht es einfach gar keine rechtliche Grundlage für irgendeine Form von staatlichen hack.
Am wir haben an die rechts Änderungsgesetze.
Gegangen das Meer überwachungs Befugnisse fürs Militär vorsieht doch sowieso Bundeswehr im Inneren
wir haben noch viel mehr Überwachungsmaßnahmen überwachungspaket gehabt wie z.b. die Erfassung von einem Kennzeichen auf Österreich Straßen die Vernetzung von Überwachungskameras im Innenministerium in Echtzeit wo dann jetzt auch in der Folge schon Gesicht
Erkennung eingesetzt werden soll
auf EU-Ebene haben wir die datenschutzgrundverordnung ganz schlecht umgesetzt wir haben uns gegen die e-privacy-verordnung eingesetzt in unserer Präsidentschaft
es wird erlaubtes dass in Gesundheitsdaten Rasterfahndung gemacht wird oder dass man anhand von meiner Medikation oder meine Arztbesuche jetzt schaut ob ich vielleicht dann
katschinka Binder so irgendwelche Sozialleistungen Mirage Leiche wir haben
verhindert das eine neue Form der Vorratsdatenspeicherung Telekommunikationsgesetz kommt.
Und da bin ich stolz drauf und ja Bildungsdokumentation war noch so ein Thema also das wirklich von vier Jahre alten Kindern bis zum Abschluss von Schulbildung und University.
Bitte genau aufgezeichnet wird wie man betragen war welche Leistungen nicht gehabt habe und eben auch mit.
Wirkung der Kinder also dass du wirklich so in der Schule in Fragebogen bekommst wie viel Bücher habt ihr denn zu Hause und die Art.
Oettinger wo halt die die Kinder verwendet werden um über die Thermografie des Haushalts Dinge zu erfahren und.
Datenberge die da angesammelt werden bei den Schuhen die können auch vom von staatlicher Seite aus zugegriffen werden und sollen auch der Forschung offen stehen.
Von konformitäts Speicher Tor geht ja schon fast ein bisschen Insel diese chinesische Betragens Datenbank.
Genaues ist auf jeden Fall auch schon so dieses Torschuss Goreng darauf bereitet man sich
und was auch noch kommt ist ebenso er algorithmische Einordnung von Arbeitssuchenden also wer zum Arbeitsmarktservice in Österreich geht der wird vielleicht auch bald
von einem Algorithmus gefeilt
und der entscheidet dann anhand von von Dingen wie hart du bist eine Frau und hast jemanden in deinem familiären Umfeld den du pflegst hast du dich niedrigere Jobchancen kriegst du vielleicht keine Schulung mehr bezahlt.
Das ist leider nicht das Gesetz gekommen sondern hat das AMS einfach so durchgeführt da versucht mir jetzt auch dagegen zu klagen und wir sind da auch dran
hast uns doch noch so außerhalb der Regierung passiertes wir hatten einen sehr lustigen Post kann der als es rausgekommen ist die Post die auch adressverlag in Österreich ist.
Daten über
die Partei Affinität von Personen herausgegeben hat und daraufhin gab es eine riesige Welle von Auskunftsersuchen an die Poster wo wir auch mitgeholfen haben mit Formularen.
Woher wissen die denn das.
Berechnetes aufgrund von Daten der wahlsprengel
also da wo du lebst das wissen Sie ja wie haben die Leute dort gelebt wie viel Leute sind dann im Haushalt und dann berechnen sie halt einfach mal die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass du diese oder jene Partei wählst
und hier gibt's leider auch keine Möglichkeit der Richtigstellung weil das Jahr
populistische Aussagen sind und normalerweise kann ich Daten die über mich gespeichert werden korrigieren aber.
Er versucht den taktischen Aussagen ist und weil die Post sich halt sogar gegen die Auskunft bei manchen Fällen.
Gibt es auch von unseren Formular wie man gleich Beschwerde einlegen kann bei der Datenschutzbehörde um sozusagen den ganzen vielleicht den Riegel vorzuschieben und der passt doch mal mit einer ordentlichen Strafe zutrauen
am das ist so in den Apfel fast so in Österreich passiert ist die letzten eineinhalb Jahre.
Anderthalb Jahre meine Herne na gut also man kann ja in gewisser Hinsicht etwas froh sein dass.
Dass das zumindest jetzt erstmal ins Stocken geraten ist und vielleicht führt es ja auch mal zur Besinnung auch für dich da die Hoffnung noch nicht so ganz entwickelt habe.
Am
ich bin Berufs Optimist und und ich finde irgendwie dass das letzte was sie uns nehmen kann ist die Hauptzollamt gerade solche
taddl wie wie das letzte Monat ist das hilft mir auch wieder so ein Paragraph zu schätzen und zu sagen ja doch es ist was anderes möglich und gar jetzt auf diese ExpertInnen Regierung und die freien Mehrheiten er kann sich schon noch was tun
und und es ist jetzt wenigstens der ursprüngliche Plan ins Stocken gekommen und es liegt hat jetzt eine Opposition
die Parteien dass es ist sicher ein guter Zeitpunkt an die Politik zu gehen für viele Leute weil vielleicht ist jetzt der Moment wo wo sich viel Leid durchdenken doch eine andere Form von Politik wäre möglich.
Sag mir doch mal in die nahe Zukunft jenseits von nur.
Netzneutralität ist ja so dein Lieblingsthema eigentlich der letzten Jahre gewesen und ist es sicherlich auch immer noch du hast auch auf der letzten Republica einen Vortrag gehalten dazu
ich muss zugeben ich habe jetzt noch nicht angeschaut was hast du denn schönes erzählt.
Abend ich habe paar
die Staus auf der Republica genutzt mal über 5g zu sprechen 5g ist vielleicht schon einigen ein Begriff das ist der neue Mobilfunkstandard nach 3G 4G kommt jetzt 5g die Frequenzauktion ist in Deutschland auch schon über die Bühne gegangen ich glaube 6,7 Milliarden hat das eingebracht
und es gibt einen enormen Hype eigentlich weltweit rund um das Thema netzzentrale rund um das Thema 5g und Dezentralität und vor allem werden das Gegensatz verstanden also man hört
wird dich in vielen Teilen der Welt V und Dezentralität gar nicht zusammenzubringen sind und das mit V Java all unsere Probleme gelöst werden riesiges Wirtschaftswachstum superschnelle Netzer überall auch am Land und
diesen gegenheit wollte ich ein paar Fakten entgegensetzen mit meinem Tag und habe halt einfach mal dargestellt so
wenn wir so oft keiner der Wellenlängen gehen wie das bei 5g vorgesehen ist dann
werden die Funkzellen kleiner dann werden auf einmal Mauern
Glasscheiben und auch schon irgendwie Regenwolken zum Hindernis und Regentropfen und Nebel zum Hindernis für diese Wellen und das hat sich Bauch einfiel feinmaschige Rasse Mobilfunknetze und viel mehr Glasfaser ist im Moment vorhanden ist vor allem wenn man fünf gehen die Fläche bringen will.
Also das bezieht sich natürlich nur auf die neuen Frequenzen die jetzt genutzt werden sollen also die höheren Frequenzen die erfordern das ja in gewisser Hinsicht also höhere Frequenz heißt ja immer auch
mehr Datenübertragung möglich aber eben auch automatisch nicht so viel Reichweite
und eben höhere Wahrscheinlichkeit an solchen Hindernissen hängen zu bleiben ne wären so die klassischen GSM Frequenzen ja noch so unter dem Gigahertz lagen und eben die Möglichkeit hatten sich sowohl weit über die Felder ausbreiten zu können als eben auch
mehr oder weniger problemlos durch Häuserwände durchzugehen aber man will natürlich nur die höheren Datenraten haben man braucht sowieso kleinere Zellen einfach damit man mehr,
Punkte hat wo man daneben ins Festnetz einsteigen kann und Jan diese Daten auch übertragen zu können.
Das also nur alle zehn Kilometer irgendwo zu bündeln 5g ist ja einerseits eben Nutzung neuer Frequenzen aber auch Alter Frequenzen mit
den neuen Protokoll indem er neue Rahmenbedingungen im allein durch das Protokoll geschafft.
Genau und diese Rahmenbedingungen sind auch so ein bisserl das was als Widerspruch sind Dezentralität dargestellt wird nicht gehen den Tag auch über die Technik network slicing ein network slicing ist
Amer Wiener quality of service wirklich ganz tief unten auf dem Radio Access leer also
das erlaubt eigentlich viel genauer zu unterscheiden wie gut oder schlecht Einzeldaten
mehr Pakete übertragen werden und wirklich auch soll das Netz in einzelne Slices in einzelne Schichten oder Segmente aufzuspalten die dann auch logisch getrennt sind und z.b. besonders Bandbreiten optimiert sind besonders energieeffizient besonders wenig Latenz haben derartige Dinge
anthem wir sehen.
Das wird wahrscheinlich vor allem benutzt werden um mir das erstmal das Telefon E-Netz zusammen was ja selber auch IP-basiert
dann ist aber sozusagen noch mal ab zu
Grenzen von anderen Datenübertragung um da eben die entsprechende Qualitätssicherung auch zu ermöglichen das ist ja auch total sinnvoll sicherlich wird auch irgendsoein internet-of-things und Notruf Lehrer an der Stelle
realisiert werden damit gibt's ja noch andere Anwendungen die ich jetzt.
Ja da hast du schon gesagt internet-of-things ist so eines der Dinge wo man sich Gedanken machen sollte weil.
Moment kannst du halt wenn du so ein Gerät kaufst hast du einen universellen Stromstecker damit das Power hat und du hast einen universellen Netzzugang wenn du ein WLAN zu Hause hast
und dann Weiteren soll hat gerüttelt werden dass du vielleicht dann das T-Mobile EOTA
die Aldi SIM-Karte brauchst damit das Ding sich überhaupt ins Netz
bin gerade an das ist die Form von vertikale Integration über die 5g sich dann rentieren soll für die Mobilfunker und da gibt's dann natürlich schon massiver jetzt virtualitäts Probleme.
Ah das sind wir in dem Themenfeld von Spezialisten über die wir in Europa so viel geredet haben kann man machen muss aber dann eben den Anforderungen des Gesetzes genügen.
Und leider ist halt in Teilen hat die Industrie bei 5g die Dinge diese,
bitte nicht durchgebracht haben einfach in der technischen Standard reingeschrieben
das ist insofern für Europa relevant weil wir jetzt gerade die erste Weltregionen sind die versucht 5g Netz Zentralität auf den Nenner zu bringen
in den USA gibt es keine Netz Oralität mehr der wird auch wieder massiv gedrosselt in Kanada schaut man sich irgendwie 5g noch erst an und ist noch nicht
dabei wirklich große Würfe zu machen die haben eine Zentralität in Kanada in Indien ist es ähnlich und in Südkorea hat man das dortige netzzentrale Teetz Gesetz gerade zurückgenommen als Vorbereitung für den 5g Rollout
der Opa ist gerade die einzige Region die beides hat 5g und Dezentralität und deswegen ist die laufende Reform der letzte tolle Tipps regeln auch so dicht,
weil wir ja vielleicht wirklich einen globalen Standard setzen deswegen war ich auch kürzlich zu Ende Mai in Brüssel auf einem Stick oder Workshop.
Derek dem Dachverband der Telekom Regulierungsbehörde nimmt immer die Pineta drinnen sitzt und da gibt's auch ein schönes Video wer sich das anschauen will.
Es ist aber 5 Stunden lang und mehr oder weniger me versus Telekom Industrie auf das Kontinent wo wir halt fünf Stunden lang gestritten haben über alle möglichen Themenfeldern
da wurde halt auch viel RV-Fach Ebene diskutiert
man sieht auch schön dass die Telekom industria hier eigentlich alleine ist und außer ihnen niemand diese Vision von einem 5g Netz richtig teilt die Reform die auf EU-Ebene passiert ist jetzt noch auf Arbeit übernimmt
also jetzt sind sozusagen die Expertinnen und Experten in ein Regulierungsbehörden Umzug am Ende des Sommers wird das dann auf Chef Ebene eskaliert.
Das Wetter der öffentliche Konsultation über die neuen Regeln geben Oktober November und dann f**** ich Finalisten wir wie es ausschaut im.
H2020 wenn ihre Form abgeschlossen ist und wir haben uns jetzt auch schon
sechs anderen NGOs mit orall testimony unwritten testimony zu Wort gemeldet und ich bin nächste Woche auch in Riga wo die Debatte weitergehen wird wieder auf einem Berg Event also das ist das ist so auf EU-Ebene was passiert
und in Deutschland ist das Thema auch weiterhin aktiv
können schon verlautbaren ist es ziemlich sicher die Deutsche Telekom wird nächste Woche ihr streamon Produkt erweitern also das wirds.
Wanda Konzert mal ne Frage diese ganzen Events sind die perse offentlich oder bist du eingeladen.
Teils teils also wenn man wenn man mitbekommt dass die sind kommt man da mit einer einfachen E-mail rein
Wann muss ich noch rechtzeitig anmelden und wenn man den Kalender von Barack auf direct. Europa.eu sich regelmäßig anschaut oder an alert abonniert hat so wie ich dann kriegt man einfach mit was da passiert und
dann gibt's natürlich auch noch andere Wege weil
die gewisse orchestration eingeladen werden auch Stellungnahmen aufzugeben und da gehören wir inzwischen dazu aber wer sich nur interessiert kann entweder den Livestream schauen oder Vorort hinkommen.
Das mit den Reisen nach Brüssel zahlt hat alles irgendwie epicenter works mein Arbeitgeber aber an sich ist ja auch eine interessierte Öffentlichkeit Platia bekommen.
Sowas mit der Telekom und streamon.
Ja wir erinnern uns die Telekom hat ja diese streamon Produkt was sie auch ganz groß bewirkt auch mit Justin Bieber darüber kann man.
Im ohne Datenvolumen zu verbrauchen unbegrenzt Musik streamen oder Video streamen an wenn man die teuren Hybridbus.
Und unbegrenzt Justin Biebers.
Am diediedie dieses Produkt ist ne.
Wandel in letzter Zeit jetzt Verletzungen weil weil darin wird auch gedrosselt wer das Video schauen will kriegt das nur in SD Qualität außer man hat die teuren Hybridprodukte dann kriegt man es auch ungedrosselt in HD und ja
die diese diese Leitzentrale tierverletzung ist seit zwei Jahren auf dem Markt und es hat sich immer noch nichts getan und jetzt wird sie eben auch ausgewertet dir soll es auch einen Social und einen.
Pass geben das heißt man kann dann auch als nicht Facebook nutzen WhatsApp nutzen
a dafür zahlt man laut den Verlautbarungen 5 € im Monat und dann ist das sozusagen aus dem normalen Datenvolumen ausgenommen eben gesehen rated.
Indische Verhältnisse.
Kaninchen wäre das alles verboten die haben an supernatural RTS Gesetz Torten sind ihr so wie in Lateinamerika oder wie in Afrika wo dann halt irgendwie whatsapp
ganz groß auf der Werbung draufsteht und damit die Leute ja keine anderen Messenger verwenden ist die von Facebook
ein Tier das dieses Produkt jetzt weiter ausgeweitet.
Finde ich AD verstößt wir haben erst im Jänner eine Studie rausgegeben wo wir mal eine Vollerhebung von einziger Rating Produkten gemacht haben.
Der jetzt schon 186 solcher Produkte in ganz Europa und es werden einfach nur noch mehr.
Weil die Regulierungsbehörden ihren Job nicht machen dann hättest Du immer locker verbieten können die Bundesnetzagentur hat sich einfach dagegen entschieden und
ich will da noch noch mal verweisen in in Ungarn hat T-Mobile nämlich ein sehr ähnliches Produkt auf den Markt gebracht und dort hat die Regulierungsbehörde NMHH dagegen entschieden und hat zumindest die Drossel färbt.
Antarktis tavar T-Mobile in Berufung gegangen gegen dieses diese Entscheidung und in Ungarn ist
exakt dasselbe Produkt jetzt sogar schon beim LG h gelandet also in Ungarn ist der Rechtsweg so schnell dass das wirklich bis zum europäischen Höchstgericht
gegangen ist da gibt's jetzt eine Frage über die da RGH wahrscheinlich Ende dieses oder Anfang nächstes Jahr entscheiden wird
die ist enorm wichtig weil wenn der der Europäische Gerichtshof sich hiergegen die derzeit alle Date entscheidet dann können wir das schöne Gesetz was wir da jahrelang geschrieben haben in die Tonne treten
wenn es nämlich genau diese Art von Diskriminierung erlaubt die Deutsche Telekom macht das mal einfach in den Vertragsbedingungen reinschreibt
niemand diskriminiert und dann ist es okay also es geht darum ob ich den gerne rein Gleichbehandlungsgrundsatz das worum es ja bei deiner Zentralität geht in den Vertragsbedingungen aushebeln kann
antam.
Andererseits wenn die sich gegen die Telekom aussprechen dann hat es natürlich auch gleich global europäische Bedeutung.
Genau es geht bei den vier Fragen die dann beim Allerheiligen auch zum Teil um sie Rating die könnten auch sehr positiv für uns ausgehen falls Sie negativ ausgehen dann hätten wir hatten großes Problem
Hamann ich will nur einfach mal den Vergleich ziehen das streamon Produkte in Deutschland kam Monate vor dem ungarischen ist immer noch
existent am Markt seit über 2 Jahren und es ist gerade irgendwie das Eilverfahren abgeschlossen und jetzt ist man auf dem Weg zur zweiten Instanz in Ungarn kam das Produkt Monate später und ist bis beim arabischen Höchstgericht schon.
Frage mich was der Unterschied ist könnte es sein dass in Deutschland vielleicht die Regierung dann doch noch Anteil erhält an dem Unternehmen.
Korrekt so ist ja nur so als kurz Zusammenfassung von dem Thema Netzneutralität und ja.
Arm zuletzt und wir müssen schon total auf die Zeit schauen wollte ich noch von der rightscon berichten ich war nämlich letzte Woche in Tunesien auf einer
Konferenz am divide conversie nicht kennst ist
eine Veranstaltung von existen Audi findet jedes Jahr statt immer in anderen Städten und es ist sehr groß und der globale so.
Nicht groß wie zitiert sie Verhältnis ist ungefähr 2.500 Teilnehmerinnen aber die kommen wirklich aus allen Ecken der Welt das Oma hat er ganz viele Leute aus Lateinamerika aus Asien zum Teil auch aus Afrika.
Die einzigen Länder die fehlen sind eigentlich Russland und China und Japan so ein bisschen aber es ist halt wirklich ein guter Ort um sich zu Fernet
und dass das ganze jetzt in Nordafrika war oder gerade in Tunesien finde ich ein gutes Zeichen weil wenn irgendwo der Gedanke des arabischen Frühlings noch da ist und und Demokratie ne Chance hat dann ist das in Tunesien
am und insofern
was auch irgendwie so meine Hoffnung dass das da mal hingeht und sie haben es dann geschafft doch mit ihm viel Unterstützung der der tunesischen Regierung leider gab es dann halt einige Schönheitsfehler,
jedoch ein paar kritische über diese Veranstaltung berichten einerseits mal das in Tunesien zu machen war.
Natürlich schön weil eigentlich mal auf dem afrikanischen Kontinent gleichzeitig war es extrem schwierig für Leute aus Afrika dahin zu kommen weil die meisten Flüge nach Tunesien geht entweder über den Nahen Osten oder über
Europa und inzwischen ist es so dass man als afrikanischer Mensch auch wenn man nur umsteigt in Italien z.b. um dann weiter zu fliegen in ein anderes afrikanisches Land
Transitvisa braucht und diese Transitvisa sind nicht so einfach zu bekommen.
Arm deswegen waren gerade aus vielen anderen afrikanischen Ländern weniger Leute da ist bei anderen Veranstaltungen.
Was gibt überhaupt gar keinen Flug Kreuz in in Afrika so richtig ne außer flydubai aber das zählt ja nicht.
Ja also dann bist du halt wieder nach außen und so ginge aber ist halt doch signifikanter umweger.
Am das ist das warm Problem ist mir auch erst auf der Veranstaltung wirklich bewusst wurde das Programm war eigentlich ganz spannend
sind wirklich 20 parallele dragstart also sehr sehr viel Programm das parallel läuft und man hat eigentlich eh keine Chance sich da alles anzuschauen was man spannend findet es ging ganz stark und plattformregulierung also Umfragen von.
Netzpython fake-news und um eilig.
Intermedial liability also der soll die Plattform haften für die Inhalte die die Nutzer dort posten das war wirklich so ungefähr 60% des gesamten Programms und ist natürlich auch für
am
die großen Internetfirmen tja Finanziers von Access nach Hause und die kriegen sehr viel Geld von Facebook von anderen Silicon Valley Firmen ein großes Thema es gab auch sehr viel im Programm zu
Diversität und Inklusion und und sehr viel
positive Texte im reflexiv für die einzelne für die eigene Community es gab ein paar Torx zu
Datenschutz und und EA also die die Regulierung von Algorithmen
am was leider gänzlich gefehlt hat in dem Programm zum das habe ich kein einziges er schon gesehen ist Copyright also Urheberrechte
bei überhaupt nicht immer obwohl die EU gerade dieses große Gesetz beschlossen hat das fand ich sehr.
Schade bei der gelbe ist viel zu sagen und ja es ist schon so ein bissl dieses Programm hat halt auch das Problem
der Großteil der Sessions dort sind panel.
Also dass du wirklich ein Thema hast und dann hast du einen Host und drei bis sechs Leute die die daneben dort sitzen und eigentlich so ein bissl jeweils ihre Sicht auf dieses eine Thema darlegen und dann auch noch mit
polikum Beteiligung also eigentlich nimmt man sehr wenig mit außer man hat wirklich angestrengt zu und sind wirklich Leute die auch ihre Punkte rüberbringen können in seinem Seiten AA Kongress und achenkamp haben wir ja er
die starke Tendenz keine Penis zuzulassen aussehen
absolut nicht seine Situation sondern wir wollen hat wirklich dass ich einzelne Leute oder Gruppen von Leuten wirklich Gedanken machen und ihre ihre dem präsentieren und danach kann man diskutieren aber eben nicht nur Panels wo alle die die Gesprächszeit sich so dividiert dass jeder nur 5 Minuten redet und eigentlich nicht rüberkommt.
Ja aber redet auch nicht wirklich miteinander sondern man redet eigentlich jeder versucht hektisch in diesen paar Minuten die er dann noch bleiben.
Möglich die eigene Position darzustellen und deswegen geht es nie eine wirkliche Diskussion über und ja es ist glaube ich habe an dieser Stelle auch schon x-mal gegen Panels geradelt bin ein ganz ganz ganz
starker Verfechter alternativer Formate was ist ja im Prinzip schon schon richtig gesagt wie findest du es auch mal so ein bisschen Faulheit
von Veranstaltern alles auf so komische panels.
Finde ich auch wieso das aber alles Penis sind hat sich dann für mich aber später erleuchtet weil ich.
Es sind einige einige gute Bekannte und Freunde von mir sogar die früher bei großen NGOs waren im Netz
ethischen Bereich jetzt zu Firmen übergegangen dass einige Leute haben Jobs angenommen in Silicon Valley am und habe ich auch mal mitbekommen ja.
Wenn wenn so ein Mitarbeiter in Sondersession geht ist es danach seine Aufgabe aus wirklich steht so ist die Erwartung des Arbeitgebers dass ein genaues Briefing schreibt werden was gesagt hat.
Also gerade diese Session Format eignet sich natürlich besonders gut wenn du als Firma wie Facebook oder als staatliche Andy.
Ein Gefühl dafür bekommen wisst wo denn die Debatte gerade ist überall
dass du möglichst einigen für die Chance gibst mal was preiszugeben über ihre Position und das dann soll ich aufnimmst aber brav niederschreiben lässt und halt einfach Information gering zu machen und dein Bild.
Darüber wie die netzpolitischer NGO Szene zu diesen Themen steht ähnlich besorgniserregend sind die Berichte die Michaels haben dass es
betrifft uns in Europa nicht zumindest nicht in Westeuropa wenn du an dieser Konferenz teilnimmst dass manchen Ländern ist damit zu rechnen dass es gewisse staatlicher Akt.
Die dich vielleicht mal zur Seite nehmen und mit dir ein Gespräch führen wollen über die Situation in deinem Land und das da eben auch.
Aktivisten Aktivisten die eigentlichen kommen um sich mit akademiks oder oder anderen NGOs auszutauschen auch mal eine staatliche Nähe bekommen
die sie vielleicht nicht beabsichtigt hatten oder die Ihnen vielleicht doch auf den Kopf fallen könnte insgesamt
Access now ist eine globale Organisation die aber durchaus an eine starke amerikanische Perspektive auf viele Türme hat
ich finde die Arbeit die da in Europa gemacht wird exzellent gerade die Leute die in Brüssel auf das von Access now sitzen am Hammoor mitgeholfen bei dem Kampf für ne Zentralität für die Dart.
Grundverordnung und einige andere Themen aber im globalen Süden ist
die Auswirkung von so einer totalen großen Angie oh die dann irgendwie.
Ventosol parachuting in die halt irgendwie so ah hier ist gerade ein schlechtes Gesetz dann kommen wir jetzt schnell reine dieses Land mit all unserer Öffentlichkeit.
Und und und unsere Expertise lösen diese seiner Problem dann sind wir wieder weg und das ist natürlich dann für die Leute Lokal diese Arbeit vielleicht schon seit vielen Jahren machen.
Die müssen versuchen sich da auch eines duktur aufzubauen nicht immer positiv wäre.
Haben und deswegen freut mich auch dass es jetzt inzwischen öffentliche Kritik gibt wir verlinken hier auch einen Typ von Sony labral der so schön gesagt hello Party.
Fashion for pause for the next riot.com neo-colonialism in the natural white Sektor how the labour of individuals and organizations from the global south.
Pferde invisible heißt and raised by Node natural rights organizations.
Das ist glaube ich schon alles löschen die es auf jeden Fall geben sollte auf der nächsten weitzgarten und eine bestival
die die die ganz wichtig ist gerade für eine Konfetti viel auf Inklusion und Diversität schaut ist es wichtig da auch solchen Stimmen vielleicht sogar auch eine Bühne zu geben und sich kritisch mit denen auseinander zu setzen
und ja ich glaube dass das spanisch ist die nächste weit kommt wird in Costa Rica sein.
Und für die übernächste ist hinter Delhi in Indien und Australien Sydney.
Wann willst du da immer hin.
So sehr reisefreudig ne.
Ja also ich die du weißt meine 0:15 Uhr kommen ich ich ich bin schon öfter dort gewesen und
weil ich es auf ein für mich ist es schon einerseits wichtig diese Vernetzung zu haben ich fand es immer wichtig nicht nur in Österreich zu sein sondern globale Vernetzung macht schon extrem viel Sinn weil die
die Probleme die wir an einer Stelle der Netzpolitik haben die tauchen eure Überweisung Server die Technik ist ja die gleiche und die die schlechten Ideen der Politiker verbreiten sich ja auch
also für mich ist es schon Verletzung und auch Informationen sammeln ein Hauptgrund inzwischen ist es aber auch
muss ich ehrlich zugestehen die Suche nach nach funding Möglichkeiten dort weil du hast auf diesen Konferenzen sehr viele der großen Fahnder wie vor zum society Foundation wie die Nummer kussi Foundation und obwohl wir den Großteil unseres Budgets von Spenden bekommen hauptsächlich für nationale Arbeit ist es wichtig.
Präsent zu sein und dort auch Tags zu halten.
Du überhaupt gesehen wirst ich kenne glaube ich keinen einzigen fahren da die hat zum CCC Kongress oder zum Camp kommt auch auf der Republica sind die ihr seid
also wenn du an diese internationalen Töpfe ran willst musst Du fast präsent sein und nachdem
mein Gesamtbudget für die Netzqualität Reformen Europa exakt 0 € beträgt obwohl wir eigentlich die einzige Umsetzung sind die aktiv an dem Thema arbeitet muss ich da einfach vor zahlen
ans Abend deswegen ist es zum Düssel an double bound und
vielleicht bin ich jetzt auch hier gerade ein bissl auffüllen als ich das sonst wäre weil ich bin trotzdem ist es wichtig dass man diese Dinge offen ansprechen und kritisiert weil gerade in Deutschland sieht man eine andere Art von Netz.
Die die in anderen Länder dann auch vermissen.
Ja
super Thomas das war eine schöne Zusammenfassung des österreichischen Dilemmas und ja der kommt den Herausforderungen in Europa wird jährlich ganz.
Spannseil zu See.
Wie sich jetzt das Rollout des neuen Europaparlament so angeht was da wer da Parlament Präsident wird wir Kommissionspräsident wird es ja noch total offen also
vollkommen unklar neue Stärkung des liberalen Preis und der Grünen
keiner weiß genau was wo der nächste Kuhhandel im Personalkarussell da sein wird
von da lässt sich auch noch sehr schwer abschätzen wohin die Reise geht denke ich nur in Europa.
Auf jeden Fall also ich glaube nicht dass da irgendwer sich.
Ich traue mich auf jeden Fall keine Prognosen abzugeben aber dass dass das wird ein ein heißer Sommer auch wenn Sie gerade so anfühlt es wird nirgends Regierungen haben die noch irgendwas tun also zumindest in Österreich und Europa es werden gerade weichen Gestell
anta
die die die europäische Landschaft wird noch viel wichtiger in den nächsten Jahren wenn wir uns über E-Commerce Reformen plattformregulierung streiten werden und
wir sind lang über den Punkt hinaus weil die Politiker das Internet nicht verstanden haben sie haben eine klare Vorstellung von dem was passieren soll und wir sollten uns dringend
mit unserer Vorstellung da auch in die Debatte einbrennen.
Nach war das noch schöner als sie nicht wussten worüber Sie reden.
Da hatten wir auf den bessere Witze irgendwie.
Die geht das schon nicht aus Thomas du musst los machen jetzt hier den Deckel drauf vielen Dank.
Und ich muss noch tanken das habe ich jetzt ganz vergessen.
Ja dann mal.
Ja immer da immer nah
Amazon Wunschliste hatte über Jahre nicht funktioniert und jetzt zum ersten Mal habe ich die repariert was ich höre ab beschwert haben dass sie mir nicht schenken dürfen.
Jetzt kann man mir die richtig was schenken wenn man das will und deswegen kann ich mich jetzt auch schon bedanken und zwar bei Richard und bei C&A
Kujau Jarno.
Sehr schön genau die ist dann auch verlinkt bei uns auf der Webseite da wo auch die tollen schoonoord sind so mit allen schicken links etc.pp ihr wisst schon Logbuch Netzpolitik.
De ja oder sind Wassern für heute sagen einfach tschüss.
Aux